[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
mein lieblingsrezept für cookies mit
leckeren und erfüllung
und wir brauchen gar nicht so viele
zutaten und zwar sind das 320 gramm mehl
200 gramm weiche butter 190 gramm
braunem zucker ca 200 gramm nutella 200
gramm bei festo schoko drops einer größe
l und ein gehäuften teelöffel backpulver
und den vermische ich sofort mit dem
mehl als erstes gebe ich die butter und
den zucker in meine rührschüssel und
vermisste das ganze mit einem
handrührgerät
[Musik]
nach ca 3 minuten rühre ich dann ganz
kurz noch das sei mitunter jetzt gebe
ich noch das meer nach und nach dazu und
mixe bis sich alles miteinander
verbunden hat
und hier noch ein kleiner tipp falls sie
merkt dass die masse etwas trocken ist
dann gibt ruhig noch ein schluck milch
dazu
und zum schluss gebe ich nur noch die
schoko drops dazu
und damit wir den teig nachher besser
formen können gebe ich jetzt noch
frischhaltefolie drauf und gibt es für
30 minuten in den kühlschrank
anschließend nehme ich mir meinen großen
eis portionierer damit ich gleich große
cookies auf den tag drücke ich mir dann
in meiner hand flach und formal eine
kleine mulde und da gebe ich dann einen
großen klicks modellreihen und
verschließe das ganze wieder die talk
google gebe ich dann auf meinen mit
backpapier ausgelegtes backblech
die cookies drücke ich noch mit feuchten
händen etwas flach und damit nicht nur
in schönen schokoladig ist sondern auch
außen gebe ich noch ein paar schoko
drops auf die cookies
und das ganze kommt jetzt für 16 minuten
in den ofen und das ist das leckere
endergebnis ich finde die cookies können
sich echt sehen lassen und sie schmecken
so lecker und vor allem mit dem weichen
kern
ich kann es euch nur ans herz legen und
falls sie gerne mehr davon sehen möchte
dann lass mir gerne ein abo da bis zum
nächsten mal auf geht s kitchen